hey willkommen zum heutigen video leute
in afrika von euch fragen schicken
lassen und war aus märkten angucken oder
thema der fragen ist macht und luca also
einfach beweisen unsere freundschaft mal
was auch immer keine ahnung sagt sie
wollen sie nicht sind frage noch mal ein
nicht schlecht muss ich sagen da sind
manchmal auch wird also ziemlich offen
dass dieses foto gemacht wo die leute
mehr suchen sich und haben zwei jungs
und da wie gesagt wurde auch vom band
sollten die mich aus meinem privatleben
kennen darauf angesprochen und da sind
einfach komisch weil das sind wir und
auch industriegeschichte
wenn man einfach nur befreundet ist
gemütlich mehr daran aber wirklich
komisch wenn ich jetzt nicht mein stil
selten aber ein okay ich glaube die
anderen viele fragen kennen viele von
euch schon also luca sich an uns
kennengelernt
ich kann nicht genau sagen 67 jahren
also auf jeden fall gut gemacht haben im
urlaub haben wir uns kennengelernt und
wir fahren halt jedes jahr wieder in und
haben jedes jahr wieder gedreht und dann
halt über die jahre hinweg freundschaft
aufgebaut und ab dem zeitpunkt wo die
youtube gemacht haben und mit halt
irgendwie auch rom gereist bin und so
was den job verrichtet hat so angefangen
eine dreier und wenn man einmal pro jahr
dann und wann über youtube viermal im
jahr gesehen und jetzt mit 35 minuten
von verrechnung gesehen
mindestens jede woche einmal also die
entwicklung ist okay zwei fragen lebe
ich gerne mal auch entwickelt meint ein
gartenhaus 56 ließ was leute sich
vorstellen was man macht und
persönlicher wird also ich werde das mit
ich hab schon einfacher geht man einfach
so fanden die andere frage
5 dinge di luca hat das ist schwierig
fünf dazu zählen
als ersatz könnte keine 15 ich könnte
wahrscheinlich bei mir selbst ich war
unser auswendig wirklich harte rechte
ist also ein lang genug ist sollte
irgendwie angehen will
das war jetzt aber fünf sachen nicht
kennen
das war eine sehr gute fragen zu mir und
luca vorliegt
für schwierige frage also begann ich
mich viele situationen wo man das
herausfinden konnte einem wasser aber
doch ein bisschen ungerecht war zur
stelle
zum beispiel musste ich ja da mussten
wir am haus oder rauch und lukas ab
morgen aber er hat auch art von höhen 1
und ich habe gleich aus der
das werde sie eine information bekommen
zum beispiel einmal ein großer fan des
ball reingehen und lucanet kostengünstig
der musikerin keine ahnung als
wahrscheinlich auch nicht im fahrzeug
ich kann nicht genau sagen was glaubt
ihr ich weiß nicht ob wir dabei sind
überhaupt weiß nicht ob wir im team
geben dürfen weil uns jetzt muss man ist
frei
das gleiche team machen ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht aber es ist auch und wellen
wir würden seinen leuten wie beim
letzten mal war richtig cool ist und was
für ihn spricht
ok weil es zur sache auf gleichmäßigen
schlüssel mit technischen situation
zusammen also klar ein wärmespender für
weil wir irgendwie beide volk was machen
sie mit mehr rechten für tag mit
rebellion wien unterwegs und libyen aber
die ganze zeit lief und gesperrter
umgeschrieben keinem fall aber auch in
fremde leute haben geschrien und
wirklich daneben greifen und wir über
die unterwegs sind schon peinlich
zusammen mit partnerin von luca video
was die tage kommen entsprechen und das
wird cool
folgende strecken sind nicht an ein luca
wahrscheinlich schwersten einsatzgruppen
okay die frage bin ich gut ich richtig
gut
die frage war ob wir uns gegenseitig
helfen wussten mädchen anzusprechen ich
glaube nicht aber welche drei dinge
würden auch nach einem fumble nerven
können wir nun vorstellen an luca
könnten vielleicht merken dass er
bestimmte videos stellen ein stück
natürlich kochen kann auch einfach ihren
kochen kann ich keine stellung
jetzt kommt noch mal ein punkt noch 2,2
ist dass luca in mainz bei
schwierigkeiten hat einen zuzuhören da
müssen wir rein sagen hab ich selbst
auch aber nicht so krass di luca also
mein äußeres luca und reaktoren
verbessert das neue lied mit einem
trends gesehen so gucke mir das bild an
max so ungefähr ist dass man bei und
ansonsten recht schwierig das überlegen
als animierte wahrscheinlich merken dass
ich kann so paul wänden zu jagen oder
sowas könnte werden koste es ist einfach
den namen von mir rein und dann sollten
drei erstmal vielen dank neuester
aufläuft ist aktuell nicht geplant aber
beim ersten mal kam die entscheidung
auch mega spontanes machen weil der
verkannten garantien vielleicht
irgendwann noch mal gibt darauf aber ich
weiß auch das einplanen grenze gibt eine
vorstellung würde ich sagen aber das ist
noch nicht so sicher dass soweit fehlen
könnte
okay da ist das nicht anders
2000 euro die nacht suite video von
julia gaß baldige schiffenberg führen
mit sicherheit also wirklich
wir waren haben wir waren am vortag
feiern und anderen den ganzen tag bei ok
die beantwortung dieser zeigen lassen
zweimal auch weil einfach zehn minuten
dass ich noch viele video ohne ton waren
aber weshalb man auf die antwort auf die
frage die beschimpfung sagten sie wir
gemacht haben kennt ihr erscheinen sie
in gewisser art und weise schon und zwar
dass der anteil an ausflug wir waren am
vortag feiern
deine ganzen tag komplett verändert bei
luca zuhause lagen auf der couch herum
und anfang märz wieder okay wir müssen
noch was machen und so machen wir getan
wir sind aufgestanden suchen wir eine
runde spazieren und dann fangen wir
irgendwann kann ich meine zu kaffee und
vielleicht einfach angst beim
spazierengehen weil diese art von morgen
sagen manchmal auch komplett dumme
sachen und da kriegst du kann mich so an
und ich okay fällt das machen ja das ist
erst mal nur schwer spontanaktion dumm
nur dass dann alles entschieden haben
dass wir ein ziemlich vergleichsweise
teure hotelzimmer gebucht haben
wir wurden zwar noch in den montag
upgrade so dass den kompletten kader zu
testen bekommen
doch etwas sehr feier auch so das war
die spontane und verrückte aktionen und
ließ mich erinnern kann
leute ich hab mal wieder ausgefallen und
weil irgendwie informativ oder auf das
reicht für euch solche fallen lasse
gerne ein leichter wir sehen uns dann
wahrscheinlich morgen oder wieder wenn
dein video mache und ja grüßt eure
großer